Balasingham commerson and silver ssa
Burson are working illegally in a
fast-food take away the owner risking
heavy fines or even jail for employing
them makes them stay in the back out of
sight of the public cleaning and
preparing food without any legal status
they are reliant on finding people who
want to support not exploit them how
much to get paid and what you get given
sometimes 15 pound and the 20 for the
full day's work did wonderful work and
you get food yeah to attain the food
yeah
in this hope yeah always chicken yeah
they work until late at night
constantly fearful of someone becoming
suspicious and reporting them to the
council when the shift finishes we
follow the men back to where they sleep
a secret hideaway they say even the
neighbors don't know exists there we
find a garages home to a group of Sri
Lankans all of them came to Britain
illegally with fake visas as Tamils they
say they're fleeing persecution
soon after two more men arrived from a
day also spent doing odd jobs according
to a former head of immigration
enforcement this is how an estimated 1
million illegal migrants live in Britain
under the radar fearful of being
discovered when we go outside we scare
to the people also be scared to the
police or everybody who are outside
whoever seeing us so we don't like to
see the people and contact the people
but after years of fear now they say
there is a glimmer of hope because of
brexit which they believe could even
bring an amnesty for them we believe
that we can we can come up and we can
get over from the government because the
Buddhists but the European people will
go out when the word Lexus is captain so
when they go out even the Buddhist
government they need the people so so we
believe that they will offer some
opportunity to come as a legal
since the referendum these men say
things have already got better and
they've been able to get more low paid
work brexit was designed to reduce
immigration but these migrants hope it's
them who could be benefiting from the
changes it will bring Lisa Holland Sky
News